- We love our hoagies, we love Wawa.
- Fuck yeah, exactly.
- Love our cheesesteaks.
- That's like real Philadelphia.
I'd say as far as real
Philadelphia cheese steaks go,
Jim's on South Street
would be my favorite.
- It's definitely Jim's on South Street.
- I'm a Geno's girl.
Love it.
- Tony Luke's...
- I'm disappointed.
- Is my number one.
- I'm expecting dry
meat and terrible bread.
- I'm kind of a little
worried about the bread.
- I'm expecting them to
be like either too cheesy
or not cheesy enough.
- Whit wit, 100 percent.
- Bring on the first cheese steak.
- Cheese steak.
- God.
(bright music)
- Okay.
- Oh,oh.
- Looks like there's provolone on here.
- It's not Whiz.
- You gotta put Whiz on the cheese steak.
- I miss that like fake cheese flavor.
- Gummy.
- You can never get the bread.
- No, the bread, I mean,
there's only one kind of legit
bread, and this is not it.
- It could use a little love.
- There's steak and there's cheese,
but it doesn't taste like a cheese steak.
- That's not bad.
- It almost tastes more
like a cheeseburger.
- I'm gonna give it four Liberty Bells.
- Two Liberty Bells.
- I give this one a two.
- Three Liberty Bells.
- Let's get the next one.
(bright music)
- Ew.
- Um.
- Hmm, this one's a little messier.
- Are they mushrooms in here?
- This is a panini, first of all.
- Is this ciabatta bread?
- That is a big chunk of steak.
- Look how thick that is.
- Mm.
- It's got steak meat,
that's not a cheese steak.
- It's really not bad though.
- Maybe I just like all cheese steaks.
- Can I go negative Liberty Bells?
- Taste wise, I give it
like four Liberty Bells.
- I'd give it zero.
- Three.
- Good job, Denny's.
(bright music)
- Subway.
- Oh it's not called a
sub, it's called a hoagie.
- It looks the closet thing
I've seen to a cheese steak.
- Yeah.
- There's jalapenos in here.
- Jalapenos?
- Oh no, this has jalapenos.
I can't do it.
- Tastes like Subway.
- The meat is cut better.
It's not as chunky as the other one.
- The meat is pretty good.
- Meat, definitely cut better.
It definitely has more of
a consistency of a real
Philly cheese steak.
- This is the closest.
- we're getting there.
- Almost reminds me of
like when your parent
would make cheese steaks for dinner.
Three bells.
- I give this one three.
- Yeah, I'll give it a three.
Bye Hoagie way.
(bright music)
- Hooters sells Philly cheese steaks?
Get out of here.
- When did this start?
- Have you ever eaten at a Hooters before?
- There's lots of
nontraditional Philadelphia
items on this guy.
- There's mushrooms, there's some peppers.
- The vegetables are throwing me off.
Tastes kind of like a fajita.
- So this bread feels
like a baby's bottom.
- The roll feels a little soft.
- The meat in here doesn't
have a lot of flavor.
- I guess at Hooters, you know,
the flavor comes elsewhere.
- I really just want some Whiz.
- I don't know what
Hooters think they doin'.
- Sorry Hooters, I'm gonna
give you zero Liberty Bells.
- Yeah, I think this
is zero Liberty Bells.
- I give it three.
- Hooters.
- Got to go.
- Stick to wings, man.
(bright music)
- A lot of people don't
realize that like south Jersey
is basically Philadelphia.
- Oh yeah.
- This looks the most like a cheese steak.
- Mike, don't let me down.
- The bread is almost perfect.
- I can get with this one.
- Mm-hmm.
- Mmm.
- Easily the best one.
- Okay, Jersey Mike's.
- This is the cheese steak.
- It's not as good as a
cheese steak from Philly,
but it does taste like a
cheese steak you would get
like in New Jersey.
- I would definitely give
this four Liberty Bells.
- Mike's a four Liberty Bell.
- I mean, as far as the
ones we've had so far,
this is by far the five.
- Yeah.
- Y'all all right.
- Philly definitely makes
the best cheese steaks.
- If your like, I need a
Philadelphia cheese steak stat,
where can I get one?
Go to Jersey Mike's.
♪ Fly Eagles fly ♪
♪ On the road to victory ♪
♪ Fly Eagles ♪
I love you Wawa, I miss you.
(squeaking)